theoretically
yeah thanks for the invitation
today i'm going to talk about a
theoretical framework of convolutional
kernels on image assets
this is a joint work with theodore means
activities and andrea nari
andrea is my phd advisor and theodore is
a last year phd soon at stanford
and theredo is a fantastic collaborator
uh this work cannot be done without him
and theodore will be on the academic job
market in the full semester
so yeah if there's any position that is
open you should definitely consider him
so the story should start from the
imagenet competition
well you are asked to
train a classifier on the training data
set which are labeled images and
the winning team is the one that uses a
classifier to have the lowest test error
so the
uh
well this imagenet computation should
definitely be an important reason why we
are here discussing about deep learning
theory
and in the
last 10 years well
10 years ago this deep convolutional
neural networks revolutionized this
competition and then revolutionized
the field of computer vision
and well nowadays these deep
convolutional neural networks has
becoming the golden standard
well of
the computer region
and there is a question of
why
deep neural networks work so well on
this image data set
and there is a workload of the success
which says that well the convolution
structure plays well with the image that
set
well this says that well not only this
nonlinear structure of this neural
network is important
but also this convolution structure
is
an important
ingredient of the success for this
uh deep convolutional networks on this
image assets
okay
so
that means maybe like well if it is
disentangle this conclusion with neural
networks while this conclusion structure
may can
show its own strengths in this
image classification task
while this can be made
possible by using this connection
between neural networks and kernel
message but this is a famous paper the
neurotin internal paper which says that
well in the
specific regime
in the white
network limit this limit
convolution of the neural network can be
approximated by its linearization which
is in some sense equivalent to a kernel
method
so we can linearize convolutional
network and derive combustion kernels
and you can look at the performance of
these convolutional kernels versus
gaussian kernels which are the gaussian
kernels you can think about it as like
the kernel linearized from fully
connecting your network
and you can see that well on this
several turn data that well if you just
use gaussian kernel you get error 33
percent but if you use linearized
linearized uh convolutional neural
networks so you can get test error while
these are the
uh recent results you can get test error
like twenty percent to ten percent
and if you don't use uh convolution if
you don't use
uh
convolutional kernels that are
linearized from convolutional neural
networks instead use some specific
handcrafted convolutional kernels you
get calculator 10 percent
okay so that means well it's not only
this neural network that is important in
this image translation the success of
these image classification tasks while
this convolution structure itself is
important
okay so this is very intuitive because
well people would believe that this
convolution structure
plays well with the
structure of the image
well what are the important properties
of the images that people believe
play well with this convolutional
structure but definitely there is this
locality of features in the images
this is not hard to imagine well because
well things that are meaningful often
come together in a cluster
and this induce the locality of the
features and images
another important property of the image
is the translation in variance
if you give me a cat i translate this
by a few pixels this is still a catch
and while this while people believe this
is very intuitive and
well
it's a very natural intuition but my
question is how to mathematically
quantify the advantage of this
convolution and pulling operations
for this image data set
so i want to mathematically quantify the
natural intuition
and this will be
the
key question i would like to discuss
throughout this talk
and
if you have any questions just feel free
to interrupt me
okay so let's first look at how to model
the invariance
in image data set
and here i would like to first present a
generative model for all
for
what i think this image asset is
generated you can argue maybe this is
not a very realistic model but i would
like to defend that well there are at
least some important
uh ingredient that has been encoded in
this generative model
okay so
well uh definitely if you want to
generate x y pairs where x is the
covariate the pixel of the image and y
is the label of the image
and the covalent x is just the d
dimensional euclidean in the dimensional
hidden space and d you can think about
it as the number of pixels
and we consider a group that can act on
this d-dimensional opinion space for
example we can consider the ck group
where the group has d number of elements
the ice element of this group act on
this x is just the do the cyclic
translation of the covalent x by i
pixels
so it's g acting x g i x x is just the x
i to x d and then x1 to x
x i minus 1.
so we can
consider other groups for example like
2d circuit group
images are naturally two-dimensional or
there are some other groups we can
consider
and we model this label of the image the
label y
is induced by an environment function so
y is induced by this f star
an environment function the definition
is that well f of x is f of g x where g
is any element in this group
so if the group is a c group we can give
an example of what is a
sick invariant function f star well for
example this is a
degree two c k polynomial this is just
the summation of x i and x i plus one
so we assume that the label of the image
is generated through this like invite we
assume that we impose this environment
priority of this y given x
okay and we hope that this is the
stylized model of an image label
that is well environment by translation
of the image x
so for now i didn't make some assumption
on like how what the distribution of x
and how this noise is distributed
well we will put some more assumptions
on this component that will be
non-realistic but hopefully this
component of this generating model will
capture the essence of how this
image
what is the distribution of this image
that asset
okay so well this is a pictorial
representation so you have x you
translate this
uh
pixel orientation and you get g of x and
they are both occurred
and then we discuss about like the
neural networks and kernels we use to
fit it to fit this uh data center
okay so first we consider a two layer
fully connecting your network i use fc
to denote this fully connected
so it's very standard it's just
summation of a i
times a sequence function composite on
the inner product of x and w i
and here ais and w i's are the
parameters
and x is the input covariate
and this sigma is a general activation
function
while we
will put some smoothness assumption on
this sigma but well maybe like you can
think about it as like value sorry
smooth value or like a sigmoid function
by saying that the
group action you have defined here
like captures the translation in the
next line
now you're saying that the group action
you have defined in the previous
slide one
capture translation in this
yeah
the group so here i can see
[Music]
angle so like you apply like row by it
yeah yeah
but but
you can well this example is like 2d
but you can define like a
2d
matrix and you define this translation
this kind of says provide sensors or
colonize transition and we can look at
their conversation
okay so this is our
fully connected internationally
during consider
and we also consider
a two-layer environment neural network
so you can see that most of the
component of this invariant network is
the same as fully connected except that
there is an integration over the group
action and here this pi of dg is just
the uniform distribution on this group
so you want to
um like average this feature map over
this group
so if this group is a circuit group this
is just a
two layer well we call it two layer
convolutional neural network with global
average pulley
so this is a convolutional layer and you
take ai to be the same across all these
features so it's correspond to there's a
global average pooling layer but this is
not very important we just consider this
uh environmental network
and our result well we are not able we
are not smart enough to prove result
directly on these
neural networks but we are able to prove
some results on the kernel
kernels induced by this
architecture
okay so when g is a cd group this is
just yeah two layer convolutional neural
network with global average pooling and
then while there is a remark that this
is a fully no sense we will consider
later how to relax is a full window
assumption
okay so we look at there what's by
pi is uh you can think about if a
descript then this is just uniform on
these uh elements
yeah
it's a uniform measure on this group
and we can
consider their corresponding kernels and
well i will not
argue why this is the kernel well you
can go through the derivation of your
tangent the linearization of this neural
network and
um
okay you need to assume some
distributional assumption on this
uh a and w upon initialization
but if you assume a suitable
distribution of poundland then you can
derive this
kernel corresponding to a fully
connected network this is just the inner
correct kernel
so
you can there is a function h that is a
one dimensional but it maps a real
scalar to a scalar and the argument is
the inner product of x one and x two
and for environmental network this will
induce an environment kernel
so the environment kernel you can see
that this is just the average of the
inner product kernel over this group
and this is the inner product of x1 and
the g of x2
and our goal is to quantify the
advantage of the environment kernel over
fully
connected kernel to learn environment
functions
so why is it called an invariant neural
network
why this
why i call this environmental network
because
if you look at this neural network if
you shift this x by g
the function doesn't change
yeah this is uh
why i call it environmental network but
or maybe there are other
people like
uh saying environment is something
else but here
this is a reason why i call it
environmental network
yeah we want to quantify the advantage
of environment kernel
over fully okay so
i still use fc
because it's like fully connecting the
kernel induced by fully connecting your
network
and i want to quantify the language of
these when we learn environment
functions
so why is the ga only
operated on the x2 not the x1
so actually
if there's a g prime that i can explain
and continuation over g prime this is
the same voltage
the function is that the kernel is the
same current because of the
environments
so there if there's a g prime it's the
same same thing
okay so
let's look at the theoretical result
firstly
say how the data is generated so we
assume that x i y i the n samples
and here are the annual list assumption
like everyone criticized every reviewer
will criticize this assumption let's
assume it so
x i are uniformly distributed on sphere
this is a unrealistic assumption
basically it's isentropic but real
images are never isentropic
but we assume that uh f star is an
environment function so at least in this
model we capture the
environments of y given x we didn't
model we the model assumption on the
distribution of x is not so realistic
but at least the y given x in this model
is quite realistic
it's like imagining like when you take
uniformity over the sphere scale by
square root of d it's essentially taking
a gaussian yeah
why do you assume emotion i'm just
curious yeah it's a technical logical
thing yeah
okay so here is the theorem we want to
put it informal
assumes that vision smooth as unique
activation function
you can think about smooth shadow and
and
consider kernel reflection is the fully
connected and environment kernel i
denote it as krr kernel reflection xc
for fully connected and kernel
regression iv for invariant so these are
the
functions after training
and uh one caveat is that well there is
a drug resistant parameter lambda in
this kernel regression
and
here i didn't say what it is and you can
think about this lambda as uh zero
as like this is called kernel rich less
regression someone call it or you say
well lambda is something small but
doesn't destroy well there is a green
range of lambda we can take and this
result will code
uh yeah
you can think about maybe lambda zero
okay and the kernel reaction is fully
connecting your free kinetic kernel
um
will fit a degree l polynomial part of
the target function
that means well
yeah the outer error between the
kernel regression for fully kinetic
channels
will be approximately the target
function projected on the top will be
projected onto the degree l polynomial
space
is p less than l that's where l is the
projection operator of the target
function onto the top onto the
um
degree l polynomial space
and for environment kernel direction
this will correspond to the projection
of the target function onto the
degree l plus one polynomial space
so you can see that difference is that
you have uh
you fit one more degree polynomial using
this
invariant kernel rejection
i need to calculate what is l so here we
consider the regime when the dimension
and the sample size goes to ep together
um
and we assume that the sample size is
between d l and d l plus one so you can
think about l as fixed like three or
five you fix il for example three four
five but n and d are large i will show
example a numerical example where this
regime makes sense
yeah so l is small and and d are large
and we consider this asymptotic regime
and this is uh what happens and equally
you can say well the test error of this
kernel regression with fully kinetic
kernel
will be the target function of the norm
square of target function projected onto
the polynomial of degree greater than l
and similarly the similar result for
environment canon regression
so there is no as there is no
uh
you haven't used the fact that this g is
translation g can be rotation right yeah
regression will jump up like one degree
of polynomial
uh yes so yeah good question so when
then
pass through this neutral l
well then or log b pass through an
integer there is a time
so what rules are g from being the
identity
uh
g to be the lnd man
will that be just
that will be the fully content will make
okay yeah here i think g to be the
here they still require this g to be a
when d and 2d group
so
uh if it's not like say if it's like
rotational invariance this is some other
group
uh
we have some
results for that well it will depend on
the effective dimension i will make a
remark later but it will depend on the
effective dimension of that group
the the result will depend on
uh characterization of
group distribution and
because we have the
because 1d2 is simple in that sense you
just put a uniform distribution
what's the technical reason why i hear
as uniform distribution no why why this
cannot be generalized to rotation uh
the reason is that well for general
location group the the sample size we
can say is different from b is here i
want to prevent the result in a green
light so
i just consider these two rules that if
you consider general rule about this
like the n is like d to the l times t or
d l or t to b
l plus one or p and p is the effective
dimension of the group then you observe
so the reason you sit you can learn one
higher degrees because you're modding
out like this one
that's because the group is one uh the
move will be bundy what's learned
yeah
what's the technical reason you need a
smooth activation function
uh smooth a technical reason is that i
want to do a decomposition of the kernel
on two oscillating polynomials and i
need to assume some sufficient decay of
the
coefficient but that's the reason why i
need some distance so all little o1 is
that depends on this movement of the
activation function yeah if you depend
on a lot of things the legal run hiding
here here will depend on the
representing parameter will depend on
the smoothness movement
of the height
so what what i care is
yes
so here there is a numerical simulation
to understand what is this result better
and here i took some uh inversific
sticking polynomials and this is uh one
series polynomial given two and equals
three uh cd polynomial and uh what i do
is i use gaussian use fully kinetic
kernel and the cd kernel to fit
uh target functions and the y-axis is
the test error
and x-axis is the sample size and here i
plot the sample size in the log scale
and it's log d over log n over log d so
you know that while the theorem predicts
when log n over log d there will be a
fixed transmission so here um the dash
lines correspond to the place where
there should be a big transition
and you can see that well for the city
terminal
well the tax error will be like
of any function it should be smaller
than the past error of the
um
of the
fully connected kernel and
if you use like for example line to cut
these two lines across points the
distance will be of order d so you save
a d suppose uh b factor
in terms of sample size that you use in
line use sticky kernels or economical
so
here are some remarks so
the result is that would be the degree l
in
for the kinetic kernel requires symbol
size
e to the l whereas invariant
uh kernel requires d l minus one so you
say factor b
and uh yeah you can factor the in sample
complexity by using the cd kernel and
similar results for environment features
although i didn't talk about any feature
of what is when the features are in this
talk but well that's contain our paper
and
for general group
like rotational invariance for the
identity but it's not
not something interesting but
we gain a factor
uh sample size vector p which
corresponds to the effective dimension
of
the effect that i mentioned i need to
define is through
uh the group and the current so
it's uh
yes
it's uh
something like uh i don't want to
go into detail in this topic so if we
had a 2d image but our group is only one
dimension of translation so like say
just columns and not rows does this give
us a factor like square root of d or
something um
many in many cases if the group is
discrete you see a factor that is the
size of the group all right it doesn't
enter yeah yeah
but but
sometimes the book is continuous yeah
you can handle continuous group and then
you need to get
effective size of the group
okay so i would like to explain the
mechanism just a high level mechanism
why this happens
and there is a principle where well
along with this is like uh universally
known to everyone but theory business
like kernel integration which functions
in top order and either space of the
kernels are ending the sample size this
is not hard to imagine because when you
have n samples you can fit b parameters
in linear regression and in kernel
regression well under certain
assumptions this principle is also true
like you have the samples between d
directions which directions you feed
within the directions corresponding to
the identified top at the space of the
current
so that means as long as we are able to
understand what are the top and space of
these two different kernels are able to
understand what
what is the
behavior of kernel realization
for fully kinetic kernel the
eigenfunctions are certain harmonics
well
and for
environment kernels well the eigen
functions are environmental harmonies
so the number of well for a fixed degree
environment for harmonious is just a
subset of square harmonics there are
many vertical harmonies well so
for big that means for a fixture and the
number of inverse components
is
p times p times uh the number is p times
smaller than the number of three
components for fixed degree where p is
an effective size of
and so we can look at any structure of
the two kernels for the top to order d
eigen space uh for fully kinetic kernel
they are formed by degree one term
harmonics for environment kernel they
are formed by degree two cyclic
harmonics
and
for order d order d square against space
for fully connected internal they are
composed of degree two harmonics
for city kernel they are composed by
degrees three acidic harmonics so on and
so forth so you can see that well
for the same eigen space you get one
more degree while you have uh the
harmonics of one more degree for taking
the
kernel
so
this is the underlying reason why you
can face one more degree by using this
environment
demand curve
and here are some experiments on the
amnesia side and not very surprisingly
if you use ct kernel or free kinetic
kernel
and before we do this experiment we need
to do a
[Music]
nothing surprising
okay so this is the first part we talked
about the invariance between like uh
interplay between
uh architecture of kernel and the image
and look at the problem
so does your
sample prediction hold for ms as well
like if you were to like measure
like do you get a factor of d
improvement in the sample complexity
i mean if you measure what's a
complexity gain whether this is b
actually not actually nothing
the reason is that well
this amino acid is not isotopic
and
the
in the sunset scanning i remember it's
smaller than the
inspired
700
in this
data set and i don't think we gained
that large
but this is because there are some
um
the inside of the dimension of this
virus is not 700 it's like much smaller
so they're getting something smaller
is it like roughly the the like
effective dimension of that most or
something
here
expect to get like a
factor of seven
so i think if you want to measure the
same test error and if you achieve the
same test error maybe it means that they
are fitting the same part of this
target function and if you measure this
distance this
if the theory is correct this should be
g right at the same text editor you can
see
yeah
this effective inversion shows up
because
compare this to like a cnn
[Music]
like
is there still like a big gap between
how the cyclic kernel is doing from the
sample complexity and cnn
yeah and i uh
yeah he didn't do the experiment for cnn
for this
part
for some other
there's another technology
going to analyze the performance gap
between kernel and
your network we
did something but
didn't consider this convolution stuff
in that project so
yeah but yeah it's a good it's a good
question and you can see that this will
be your open question
questions
okay
and next i would like to talk about
locality so
for now it's just modeled in variance
but well there's definitely another
important part of image which is
locality
and here there are some tutorial um
intuition of like what is this
architecture so this one is a fully
connecting network
input provides a hidden layer
and
the
label
and
this each
each line corresponds to a weight
and
in fully connected network all these
ways are different
and pacific human network can be
understood as
a fully connected neural network based
on base sharing structure
so you can color all the colors not very
clearly but you can color these lines
according to some structure
and the viewing pose that
includes a constraint that's like the
lines with the same color they have
identical numerically and identical
numerical values
and then these become a
sitting in your network
and
this
because
this is just a two-layer convolutional
effort with global ios pulley
but one of the satisfaction is this
architecture we consider is that well
this convolutional
filter is the full size
video so the size of this filter is the
same as the size of the image
and in practice
people use small filters emotional
neural networks are always locally
connected with just small filters and
at one time you just look at a part of
these images and
of the
new world
so we want to model
this kind of scenario and we want to
make this architecture locally connected
this means that we specify these
weights and according to some structure
and
make it locally connected
convolutional
okay so
uh
here this is the mathematical expression
of this architecture for this cover x x
y to x d
well we further assume that they are on
the discrete cube plus classified
manufacture this is even more
unrealistic
but
well we will model what we want to model
is the conditional distribution of y
given x instead of modeling the
distribution of x
so
let's uh
say we assume this x is like this and
well here this is a notation
x sub k
sub participate we denote this as the
case patch
of this
uh
[Music]
of this image so this is x k plus 1 to x
k times q this is a
2 dimensional object this is the case
patch explanation q
and
given some ways which are q dimensional
so these are convolutional filters
they are smaller the q is smaller is
smaller than b these
dimension of x type the filter size is
of set q
and we consider because locally
connected and convolutional neural
network is induced as q
so you can see the expression well it's
not very different but the difference is
in the detail
so here this is ai aik has a sigmoid
function comes in on the inner product
of w i
and the case patch of x
so this is a
smaller that's that this is a number
that is a slower smaller dimension
and then this aik this ai depends on
this
patch
so we call this locally connected
convolutional neural
so if you do a calculation of what is
induced ngk
this is the result i just
directly write down this this is a
summation of
the kernel
commodity on inner product of x k y k
the case price of x and the case patch
of y
and we're going to analyze these locally
connected and convolutional kernels is
in no sense q
okay let's look at some properties of
this kernel
so first the range of this kernel well
you can categorize this precisely this
is the space of q local functions
the two logo functions
is the function space which is the
summation of g k
g k is a function of this x k the case
vector of x
and rgk to be different
so this is the range of this
lcc kernel
and you can also look at what are the
eigen functions of this pure local
and the
eigen functions are what we call two
local harmonics
so we can see that the x and y there are
the two
linear functions of this kernel course
function like the
priority function
this y is this eigen function they are
30 functions they are the product of
these x when i is
and qlobal function means that the size
of this s
at the
set s is contained in a
window
or offsets queue
is there any intuition for um
is the target function in an image task
being sort of local in this sense uh why
the image uh label is not in the sense
you can think about for example
but
functions like summation of x1 times x2
uh x2 times x3 so on and so forth but
you can now have a function like x1
times xd over 2. if q is less than 0.
you can you cannot have a function like
this there cannot be a component like x1
times xd or 2.
now there can only be functions like x1
times x2 times x3
is there any reason to think that that
image data sets are q local in this
sense
why images are too local well these are
like beliefs
the features for example like uh
all these uh
this thing is local right so you want to
make sense of this
so it's like you know neighborhood
pixels
so this kind of changes but i don't know
like
how to
uh
and
unless like categorizes you know
our intuitive very
interesting
and we can
look at every structure of this kernel
so for other one or the e i again states
these are degree one two local harmonics
for order d
two over d times q is our degree two
pure local harmonics so on and so forth
so
this is the eigen structure of this
q local kernel
and
one important thing is that these two
local functions are not environments
so these are just
local but non-environment so it's also
natural to consider
to local environment kernel
and here we could be considered locality
class in various they call it local
economic emotional environment
and the difference of this is that while
you impose the secondary
they are the same
so the
architecture is not very different from
a q local your network you just add a
global average footing there some
something like that so to make these top
layer rates the same
and uh
his corresponding kernel is
given like this i can do the
calculation offline and
see that this is the corresponding
kernel and you can see that the
difference of this kernel is the
previous kernel is that in the previous
kernel
uh the summation is over one index k
is the inner graph of case patch of x
and k specified
and here this is the inner part of case
capital x and p prime
the speed range of these kernels
are the safety
local functions
so the difference is that firstly this
is g k
the function g depends on the patch
the patch k but here these g are the
same across
and then functions are sticky to local
polynomials
so eigen functions
y part of x is the average of two local
functions average over the translation
of this s
and structure is that well the top order
one for the two any space these are
degree two c and two local harmonics
order two order two square and space
they are two three significant so and
and surface
so given
well this identification
given this understanding of this
hs we are able to provide some
generalization results
so suppose the target function
is oh by the way so
here this
this architecture and this kernel this
is uh
now very realistic and i think
you can try to try to use this kernel on
the martini outside and get accurate
eighty percent roughly like 17 fade work
i think i forgot was a precise number
but this kernel already performed quite
well
on
set r10
and remember that gaussian kernel they
got accuracy
35 56
on
um
investment
and and most of this architecture while
this is just two layers can boost on
your network with low average cooling
and this short angle is short field
and this sterilization result says that
well suppose the target function is
simply q local
and
very unrealistic assumption criticized
by reviewers
then the theorem says that
to fit a degree l polynomial part of the
target function
the regression is locally connected
internally past sample size to be of
order d times q to the l minus one
whereas locally connected
convolutional environment kernel
requires sample size to be
to the power of l plus l minus one
so you save a vector
so here
[Music]
the key thing is that
d is replaced by q and here
the key thing that you say with vector d
comparing to if you use full window
kernel
the sum of complexity is into l whereas
the true window environment kernel
percentage and each lms
so these are like these
polynomials are not very easy to like
well
visualize
to understand but
here we have some figures uh
new numerical examples to
help understand what are
these uh what are these
things
these things mean
okay so these are four architectures
fully connected
uh simply but uh
full set window and locally connected
convolutional and locally connected
pollution and
[Music]
[Music]
this this arrangement
yeah that's a good question so q is
typically small like
three
by three filter this q is nine
uh in the in the experiment i will do
uh
experiment with q is 10
and you can see it was uh
how about like curious 10 what is the
effect what is the financial analysis
actually so
if it's uh
that's very very small outside your
region you should cover this result
[Music]
here is that you assume your target
company is q local
so yeah assuming california is advanced
and if your target version is fillable
if you use a large filter it doesn't
make sense the generation error will be
not as good as if you use the three or
four
i mean i could use a bigger filter but
it's like just they're very small
outside right it should be zero
you need to learn
samples
in terms of approximation i understand
you're right that
the approximation will be only better
for bigger field but here i'm talking
about transition result using current
manufacturing so decided
okay and uh
i copy paste the subtle competitive
required to achieve uh to learn a degree
l polynomial for this four different
architectures
well these are the numbers that are not
easy to
parse but let's consider a specific
example where
we want to learn how to degree three
point one
q is ten
eight is thirty
all moderately
sized not very freezing not very large
and
to learn
to learn this
for
20 000 samples were specific internal
requirement 900 and
thirty thousand for local economic
conventional and
the best architecture gave you a hundred
samples to learn these types
so this is the theoretical prediction
and they exactly do the
uh experiment in this case and see like
whether the prediction is
is uh
makes sense in some in some sense
so the experiment we do is that we
choose entire function to be this
so this is a
degree three polynomial
and it's in very specific environment
and it's three local
but it's three local we did we don't use
three for two
we use ten for two
uh assume that we don't know this is
true we assume at least a ten local and
try to uh
like
and then uh let's ignore this
uh record this is some either
the
purple one
the orange one
the green one and the blue one
corresponds to the text error of this
word architecture
and this horizontal line
this vertical line corresponds to the
prediction
of the prediction of the
place of the phase transition
and there should be another line for
this uh blue
but uh they didn't uh go to like this
large uh
uh samples we just uh still had
here but you should measure that here
there's a vertical curve for the blue
and the blue lines for foreign
example
you can see that the best kernel in this
example is this locally connected
environment kernel the prediction
uh condition is like 100 and
for the past i will exactly vanish
here
and for the orange and blue and while
this uh
the taste of this transition at least
makes sense and remember that this is
not so large this is just a molar
resized
example
okay so this is all i would like to talk
about for the
results and here are some
intuition of the proof
so
to prove this result we develop a
general framework for analyzing the
performance of random features and
kernel regression in a high dimensional
regime
so this is given by this paper
review and computational common analysis
uh
well i just say some informal statements
assume that this kernel can be
decomposed
in this way and land eyes are either
monitoring some percentage
functions assuming spectral gap and
decaying assumption on the standard eyes
and assume hyper contractivity and the
concentration property of these sags
then canon regulation the sample size
and fits the top order and space
so this is a very informal statement of
this result we have proved
and
to prove this well the general idea is
that
because kernel regression is a very
simple object while everything can be
written out using like being algebra
using summation product and inversion of
matrices
for example if you want to look at what
is the correlation between the target
function and kernel rigid battery
results well we can express it as the
matrix product and then there is this
kernel inversion
this mu can be written
especially using
so that means while the technical
difficulty
is to analyze spectral priorities of
matrices
so technically speaking this is just the
analysis of elementary and literacy
results
and here are some comparisons of these
results with chemical results so
classically people mostly do
non-synthotic uh result like pruning
oral encoding kind of organization
and the minimized organs and our result
is more similar to this like high
dimensional asymptotic which impacts
initiated by this favored by learning
alkaloid
and then some further development of
this kind of high dimensional asymptotic
results
the difference instead of in high
dimensional synthetics typically
people assume the sample size dimension
goes completely together
whereas particular regions consider
fixed dimensions and large thermostats
and here are some related work
so there is a line of work that analyze
the kernel inner product matrices
and uh yeah so there are recently there
are some very interesting results by
uh theodore and by the group of below at
however so these are about like what's
the behavior of kernel inner product
matrices in the polynomial scaling the
gene then the sample size is a
polynomial of the dimension
and there is a line of work that i
talked about in variance of quality of
this kernel
method in classical regime
uh
uh very
the the work of uh
[Music]
runa and the workshop itself these are
the two favorites that are
called closely right to my talk and for
this
uh two results these are in the clinical
regime
and then there is a very interesting
result last year like this extends
the framework to multi-layer network so
it can model locality but not the
environments but
it already is very interesting because
it considered multi-layer
the kernel is used by quantitative
networks
and finally i'd like to talk about some
open questions
uh
so in our work we assume
that image provider exercise has a topic
unique from a sphere or on cue
already criticized by all the videos
and uh this is manualistic definitely
and
my hope is that well we can generalize
this
uh to real like the x distribution
people people know that
people starts in the vaguely
variable domain
so the tactics can we also model such
property of the distribution of x and
look at what's the behavior of this
kernel message
and another question is like all our
results concerning regression
but in image type
image is like image classification so
well what how to characterize the
interface
and locality in these cascading tasks
and finally like while that many people
will criticize this is not determining
this is that kernel message and so
what's uh what happens
uh
for non-linear what's the behavior of
non-linear neural network
training like
how to paralyze in variance and the
locality for
non-linear neural networks
so yeah the summary is that while here i
think
this table is a great summary of his
talk and uh
yeah thank you
[Applause]
the very last year you make it
uh in you have any thoughts that is you
can increase that you can have some sort
of equivalence in your network too
so
first yes this could be that yeah yeah
good good question so
here this work extend this to
multiplayer but didn't consider
environments that's the considerable
quality
um
so actually environments and localities
play well with each other it's not
something
trivial
it's uh you need to
there are some there are some um
something happening so that's
inconsistent but if you don't carefully
define what is like environmentality
it's hard to make them
[Music]
consistent
because this means that can have a
unified theory for for this architecture
so does that paper consider optimization
if it's only sound
sorry
this is multi-layer
the currently used by multiplayer
but yeah but
locality is incorporating these
good questions like uh
there is open thing like cultural model
environments or equivalent you know
multiplayer network
what how quality can
interfere with
the transition
yeah this is also yeah this is not there
in some sense
yeah
in some sense
this case because it's
different from the inner practice
and the paper is called like a frequency
the principle of frequency and
space and frequency printout
so
there is a tradeoff using multiplayer
kernels like the functions we can think
are like
low frequency
high space
functions or high frequency low space
functions
okay
[Applause]